hallo leute wir sind heute zurück in der
küche wir werden mit euch eine typisch
deutsche speisen operetten und zwar
machen wir heute mit euch franco
einige kennen sie auch unter einer
kuchen man kann sie süß oder herzhaft
essen und ist ein sehr beliebtes gericht
in der deutschen küche
los geht's
[Musik]
med
wir fangen jetzt an indem er den zeigt
für die pfannkuchen vorbereiten
wir werden den tag ungefähr für sieben
pfannkuchen vorbereiten damit ihr die
mengen kennt und zwar brauchen wir dafür
milch 200 milliliter hier im messbecher
dann haben wir ein zweiter messbecher
indem wir 200 gramm mehl haben dann
haben wir zwei eier damit die
pfannkuchen schön fluffig werden also
die franken hinterher nicht so schwer
und klebrig sind nutze ich immer
sprudeln davon natürlich nicht die
zweiliter aber so ungefähr 60 milliliter
ja und an küchen und fernsehen braucht
man natürlich auch noch ein paar dinge
um die von kunden vorzubereiten
das ist eine rührschüssel in dieser
branche werden in teig zubereiten
den teig verrühren wir mit einem
schneebesen
dann brauchen wir doch eine suppenkelle
um den tag hinter ihnen die fahne zu
gießen und ein sieg für das mehl damit
das mehl nicht so klumpp ich in der
suppenschüssel ankommt und dann zu aller
letzt natürlich werden die pfannkuchen
gebacken in einer beschichteten pfanne
damit dass nicht alles klingt so wir
fangen wir erstmal an das mehl durch das
sieb in der beschlüsse zu geben
das wird jetzt einige zeit dauern werden
wir euch das ein bisschen geht schon los
ich habe talent hahaha dadurch besser
für dich sehr schön
die milch kommt hinzu dass werden wir
eine prise salz definitionssache
für mich ist das eine prise ich hoffe
dass wir nicht zu salzig
so jetzt werden wir die zwei eier
aufschlagen
ich finde das eigentlich nicht so
schwierig viele menschen finden das
schwierig ich habe letztens gelesen dass
das alle immer falsch machen weil man ja
eigentlich immer hier am rand das war
auch schlecht sondern man soll das
eigentlich so machen muss man das ei in
der hand hat um einmal aufschlägt auf
der arbeitsplatte dann kommt an riss in
der mitte und man kann das gut öffnen
weil man sonst wohl immer auch reste von
der eierschale in den teig hat aber ich
mache trotzdem einer canteras mag ich
lieber los geht's
so jetzt geht's los der schnee wissen
kommt zum einsatz wir werden den ganzen
tag jetzt verrühren schön cremig würden
und dann können wir die pfannkuchen auch
schon backe ich fange schon mal ein
bisschen das ist nur etwas längere
aufgabe pfannkuche super beliebt unter
kindern
ich habe vom kuchen schon immer geliebt
ich mache ja auch jetzt noch auch wenn
ich kein kind bin aber ich kenne auch
viele kinder die versuchen sehr sehr
sehr sehr gerne mögen ja früher haben
wir das immer gemacht
so jetzt stellen wir den gasherd am fifa
wird erhitzt
jetzt kommt erstmal das öl in die pfanne
damit der frank ruff nicht anpackt das
schön in der pfanne verteilen so der
erste fan kuchen fg los den teig werden
wird in die mitte der fahne tiefe und
dann werden wir den einfach dateien
ich glaube auch noch ein bisschen mehr
uns wird in serie wird die nachrang
kuchen bisschen mit jetzt müssen wir das
mal ein bisschen backen lassen der
pfannkuchen ist jetzt schon von
einerseits leuten bewacht
das kann man mal gucken sehr gut ist
nämlich nicht angepackt und 123 okay
jetzt kann es mit dem hochstand
beitragen
ich versuche jetzt einen flip ich glaub
das wird nix
1 23
[Musik]
ich mache das was ich gemacht habe und
wie das jetzt nur aus ich werde jetzt zu
machen und frische kräuter täter auf den
pfannkuchen legen und hoffe einfach mal
das ist in der schmeckt ich muss
sicherlich probieren es muss ja mit
probieren
na das sieht doch lecker aus den klassen
wir jetzt nämlich zusammen
das sollte ein bisschen anders aussehen
nach solchen auch ein bisschen weicher
sehen aber das wird bestimmt total
lecker so ich hole jetzt mich da kam er
muss irgendwie es noch eine kleine
schlange
das haben als top acht so die stunde der
wahrheit match wird jetzt halt auch das
messer nicht so mitspielt ich jetzt
meinen herzhaften kuchen probieren
müssen mit dem käse und den tomaten
ich warte mal ab das war es geworden ist
ich habe ihn mit zeit das zu sagen so
jetzt haben wir schon fast alles
aufgegessen der ist nämlich wirklich
lecker war
so muss ein pfannkuchen von innen
aussehen
das ist ziemlich perfekte geworden jetzt
sehr sehr lecker so den zweiten
pfannekuchen machen wird in süße
variante und zwar mit apfelmus
normalerweise steht man äpfel und gibt
die stücke quasi in den teich wenn der
noch packt das mag ich allerdings nicht
so gerne ich mag es aber wenn man apfel
muss dann hinter drauf macht tatsächlich
lieber klingt komisch ist aber wahr und
den werde ich jetzt gleich auch noch
einmal mit zum probieren geben ich
glaube das hat er nämlich so auch noch
nicht gegessen
test nummer zwei wir haben jetzt den
süßen pfannkuchen mit apfelmus mit
schnitten jetzt wieder probieren
hoffentlich genauso mögen
hmm
eur lag es gut gehabt doch komisch
komisch ist nicht gut so das war es
schon wieder aus unserer kleinen küchen
und koch reihe
vielleicht habt ihr ja jetzt lust
bekommen auch vom kuchen zu backen
dann schreib mir auf jeden fall mal an
die kommentare wie ihr vom kuchen ist es
gibt wahrscheinlich tausend varianten
wie man pfannkuchen essen kann und ich
möchte sie alle wissen um auch noch mal
was anderes auszuprobieren
ihr habt ja jetzt mal zwei kleinen
eigenwilligen kreationen kennengelernt
aber erzählt mir doch normal
bf tierversuchen und ein problem das man
auch so und jetzt seid ihr dran wenn ihr
eure deutsch noch weiter verbessern
wollte dann probiert doch mal unsere app
sieht lecker aus
dort findet ihr unter anderem einen
gender trainer der euch dabei hilft die
artikel zu den wichtigsten 2000
deutschen dom zu trainieren
viel spaß dabei bis bald hallo leute
[Musik]
los geht's